all right guys bang-bang I'm here with
James who's going to teach us everything
we need to know about kovat 19 and
potential vaccines and cures before we
kind of jump into this conversation I
just want to kind of caution everybody
we're recording this remotely normally
we do everything in person but given the
remote recording the audio may be a
little shaky so just bear with us if if
anything happens but James they so much
for for joining us on those short notes
thanks for having me
let's start with your background you
know I kind of want this to be the
ultimate explanation of kovat 19
vaccines and cures but where do what is
your knowledge base come from or kind of
your training that gives you the
perspective you have sure so I guess I
really have kind of two backgrounds so
one is in medicine so I graduate from
medical school at Columbia University in
New York back in 2014 and then went on
to do ophthalmology residency so
residency in eye surgery and graduate
from that in 2018 I also studied
epidemiology during college during
medical school and did some research in
that as well
which kind of gave me another
perspective I think I'm growing a virus
in this epidemic pandemic parallel to
that background and most people on
Twitter and in this whole universe know
me is for crypto currency for Bitcoin it
was in the last year of medical school
so end of 2013-2014 and it's that first
wave of people kind of got interested in
it it really caught my attention and
within a couple weeks
it just made sense to me of some money
scarcity censorship resistant Swiss bank
account your pocket all the things that
you've said many times and then I
basically divided my time where half of
it was spent in residency which was
already busy but I also spent about 30
40 hours a week studying cryptocurrency
investing in it and so that worked out
very well in 2017 gave me the ability to
actually step away from clinical
medicine so in 2018 after I finished
residency I stepped away from clinical
medicine entirely to focus on
cryptocurrency investments in this space
ironically it's crypt
so that kind of got me back into the
medicine space again now with
coronavirus the so I guess quick aside
so black town capital is kind of what
I've been focusing attention on lately
that's a GP only fund and so that's what
we've been publishing research under but
with cryptocurrency we managed a lot of
investments in the space and it's very
volatile and it's very impacted by world
events and so when I started seeing
evidence come out of Wuhan and China of
this coronavirus it really caught my
attention I was like is this going to
come to Europe and then America and is
it going to wreck the markets and wreak
havoc and my investments and it didn't
take long for me to become convinced
that there's a really good chance it
would I'm especially when I started to
see it in Europe and then and then yeah
for the past couple weeks it just been a
whirlwind where I feel like every single
day there's a new announcement that is
surprising to a lot of people got it so
let's start with kind of kovat 19 or
coronavirus I think everyone at this
point has heard about it most people are
being quarantined or staying at home and
stay away from people through social
distancing give us kind of just a one
minute like what exactly is this and why
is it different than all of the other
kind of seasonal things that we would
see that that are somewhat related so I
think from a high level one of the big
differences from coronavirus is it's
actually is its mortality rate that was
the big controversy back you know three
or four weeks ago month ago at first
there was this is only gonna stay in
China because it's not very it's it's
why would it spread to anywhere else and
so what you have to look at is the are
not so that means for each person that's
infected how many people will that one
person infect and if it's more than one
and that means this has the potential to
turn into an epidemic or pandemic is now
more people are being infected and
recovery Crona is did that's what first
caught my attention which makes it not
different from the seasonal flu like
that can have an hour not above one but
then back
combined with this mounting evidence
especially with that ER doctor that was
kind of the whistle blower on this when
he died that really got my attention you
can't you know that death was as
prominent he was a young supposedly
healthy ER doc so this was more fatal
than the seasonal flu you rarely see
people from the seasonal flu that are
young died may be sick and then all the
way people sure
so the are not is one thing and to
compare this to other historical because
I know which I got a lot of flack for
this early on in Twitter when I kind of
started talking about the boat arrives
in early February they were just talking
about Bitcoin to talk about this though
what do you know about that and one of
the things to look I'm saying is how is
this different from the flu this is no
different from the flu and it was that
or or I was actually so north of the flu
but the second thing of someone is it is
people felt like they were being tricked
again by the media in the sense that
SARS was supposed to be this big
outbreak that didn't really seem to
amount to much Ebola but the the
difference is with SARS which is why it
realized early on this wasn't playing
out that way as SARS was not very
contagious before you started having
symptoms so it was much easier to this
is longer than a minute but I was much
easier to contain because once you got
sick you you stayed home and then you
didn't really affect anyone else the big
difference with cope in 19 now the
corona virus is that you can be
contagious while you asymptomatic so you
don't know and you're spreading it and
then you get sick a few days later but
you already infected two three or four
people so I'd say that's why this is
different than say Ebola or SARS and
then it also commands up more fatal
element than this seasonal flu our
bodies are not used to this virus
essentially got it and so before we get
into what I'll call kind of the vaccine
and cures component of this a lot of
what you just described your analysis
kind of those original alerts that you
saw red flags is all about data right
and one of the questions I think a lot
of people have is we've got a pretty
good sense of the accuracy of the deaths
recipe aggregate number of deaths
somebody died you can test them did they
have it do they not
maybe two before or after death but the
denominator to that mortality rate is
how many people actually get infected
and then how many people die there's not
a lot of testing that's gone on so how
did you consume that kind of caught your
attention in the beginning because sort
of red flags you saw cetera I think that
there's a lot of confidence in the death
number just given that people are
actually dying is pretty cv to confirm
that and you can either have test them
before after death to see if they have
this but the actual number of infected
given the low amount of testing that's
available especially in the United
States and pressor Europe or Leon how
did you think through the accuracy of
the data or kind of understand you know
how bad is this or could we just be
looking at bad data so that's a great
question and that's still actually an
important question is how many people
are we actually detecting that have
coronavirus that was one of the big
problems it's rolling out this testing
to be able to determine that and so and
even today a lot of the experts on this
including myself my opinion is a
fatality rate probably is lower than
what's coming out of state Italy which
is five percent or so there's a really
good chance that people with milder
symptoms maybe aren't going into the
hospitals to get tests that are staying
home and sure they're bedridden it could
be the worst flu worst flu of their life
but they recover but those would all be
people that lived and didn't die so that
still could be the case I guess one
thing though the point me two guys have
kind of goes in the other direction of
the mortality rate is because this is a
pandemic the amount of cases was rapidly
increasing so back in January and early
February in China when it was still
increasing he actually had to compare
the number of deaths to about the number
of cases ten days ago because when you
right when you test positive or get it
you don't die it was a 10-day delay so
looking at that delay when is rapidly
rising in China it gave me the question
this mortality rate was there was
actually a fact the other side of this
might be higher than those numbers but
then also there were maybe undetected
cases so it kind of balance that out and
it's you know you just have a rough
number but it looked like they was still
there's a musicality rate far worse than
the flu
got it that makes sense okay so now that
we understand kind of what this is and
the fact that the infection rate and
kind of the symptomatic versus
asymptomatic are all reasons why this is
more concerning let's walk through
why don't we already have either a
vaccine or a cure for this like what's
kind of the scientific explanation
behind a lack of that stuff being
available today sure so you really it's
difficult to make a vaccine for a virus
that you don't know of so this is novel
coronavirus it's new so we you wouldn't
expect us to have a vaccine for it what
we can do is isolate parts of this virus
and then introduce it in cultures in
form a weaker version of this virus that
we can then give to people that's
essentially we do it neither and when
you get a vaccine you're getting in
there dead version the virus or weakened
version and so your body most of time
you don't even feel anything sometimes
you feel a little bit under the weather
and so what that does is now you don't
really get sick but now you have
immunity to that disease so that takes
knowing the virus studying it and then
coming up the vaccine that realistically
we're not looking to have that until mid
2021 early 2020 would be a shock if we
even are able to successfully come up
with one regarding a cure for it viruses
are very hard to cure so coronavirus on
a molecular biology level the
single-stranded RNA virus so what this
means is it mutates quite rapidly so
there are times when we can cure viruses
we have cured by certain virus or the
capitai to see in the past with medicine
but it's it's notoriously hard a lot of
times what you can have is find a
treatment that can work some part of the
time and kind of flatten the curve and
how fatal this virus can be or how much
it will spread got it and so what's the
process let's start with maybe the cure
first and then we can go to the vaccine
what's the actual process that people
will go through to
[Music]
and actually validate that yes there is
something out there that can be a cure
it's a long process so you have very
early studies and cultures and then next
you have a very small trials of you know
fifty patients and then you kind of keep
rolling it up from there
the u.s. is very cautious very regulated
when it comes to studying and approving
that they approving medications and that
has saved the u.s. in the past from
certain medications behind for like the
thalidomide is a chemical is actually
very toxic to pregnant women and so this
was ruled out in Europe but the US and
wait hold the brakes on that and that
turned out to make a decision in the
situation of a pandemic though it kind
of works against us because we don't
have six months a year 18 months to be
like we're gonna find a vaccine or
medication to treat this and go through
all those proper steps which we usually
do and so that's where you know I've
kind of been focusing on a treatment
potential treatment that's already
widely available known safety effect
profile and something that about a
million people are so globally are
already on so if this could actually
cure or help reduce the symptoms or
reduce the amount of people get infected
with corona virus that could be huge it
wouldn't really you could expedite those
trials in that process much more quickly
than developing a whole brand new
treatment over the next 6 to 18 months
got it and then is it similar process
for the vaccine as it is for the cure or
is there a completely different process
with different timelines and
complexities I would say the vaccine
would even probably take a little bit
longer especially if you talked because
now you're talking about willing this
vaccine out to a large number of people
so if you're gonna also start making
like the flu vaccine when you're
recommending just about everyone in
America and the world gets this vaccine
you don't want to mess that up right
whereas a treatment you can be like okay
well this person's already sick we know
that there is a three percent mortality
rate we know that this
treatment has very favorable side-effect
profile potentially and so it's much
easier to prove that as opposed to
ruling out something that's in healthy
people that we don't you know the side
effect profile has been studied less
because there's always that concern with
about there's always that concern with
the vaccine that that weakened virus
could mutate into a harmful virus and
then you know you don't want to die from
the vaccine got it and I think that I
saw this is like the imperial college
paper that recently came out their whole
thing was even if you start identifying
what you think could be a vaccine it's
got that really long time frame kind of
12 to 14 months they said at the
earliest until you could confirm it and
it sounds like a lot of that sort of
what you're saying is revolves around
just like you can't go tell people this
can save you from cope in nineteen but
oh by the way there's your 20% chance
could kill you at the same time or
you've got after sure you know is safe
right the first three in medicine is do
no harm right so you don't want to
introduce them to something that's gonna
actually be more imposing than just you
know maybe living up the course the
disease got it okay and so talk to us a
little bit about the the potential cures
that that you're looking at I know that
there are some some encouraging I think
I think reports and data that starting
to come out now as to how there may be
some things that will actually cure this
or at least reduce the symptoms yeah so
what I've been focusing on with with one
of my colleagues is basically about it
was about two weeks ago now I started
seeing evidence coming out and
guidelines and from China and South
Korea about chloroquine being a
potential treatment for corona virus and
started doing a little more digging to
that there was some mechanisms of action
that showed how hydroxychloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine they kind of use them
interchangeably they're very similar
drugs I can talk about the differences
in a little bit but it has mechanisms to
decrease viral replication in cells and
actually eliminate that process entirely
at least in vitro and they studied this
in the SARS version of corona virus and
so there's already in me to appease the
base of amigo studies for that this kind
of idea which wasn't really talked about
yet about Corbin being and treatment of
Korres was kind of justified in my mind
when I started to see that United
Kingdom banned export of the active
pharmaceutical ingredients in
chloroquine China did similar they
essentially announced in early February
look the priority they brought him back
in the Chinese New Year early and said
hey look we need you to produce
hydroxychloroquine and high-volume we're
gonna stop all exports of this and we
need to prioritize Wuhan in our own
country to make sure that we can stop
this and then in March ninth I had been
contact with pharmacies and one of the
farmers like under in contacted the
manufacturer rising Pharma of work went
and announced and told us there's a
national shortage of it and so all these
things in my mind was like you know
basically triggered there's something
big Ewing I'm Anna Singh's either they
think cork went maybe an effective
treatment or it already potentially is
an effective treatment and so that's
when I started talking about it on
Twitter and a lot of colleagues and this
is when one of my colleague on Twitter
contact me I said hey I've been studying
for Qin for a number of years it looks
like and I know the mechanism of action
behind this very well I have a paper
that I put together take a look at it
and see what you think and I looked at
it I changed added some clinical
elements to it I was actually already
familiar with working on a clinical
level because one of the main side
effects is vision loss you can have is
very rare but you can have vision loss
from it and so I've seen a lot of
patients that were on it
and so I was able to add those elements
to it and more of a clinical I guess
impression of it and again this because
I was an ophthalmologist I saw that's
why I saw those patients and we released
that paper and it got a ton of attention
it was retweeted by Elon Musk shortly
thereafter and just kind of blew up from
there and we were contacted by the press
the media my co-author said Greg Logano
has now been on the Laura Ingraham show
he was I'm Tucker Carlson last night I
think as I went back today as well and
it's you know it's
really it's starting to become a little
bit more justified so what we had was
this kind of summary of all this
evidence I think the show the corporate
might be an effective treatment and then
what I announced yesterday which was
remain in contact with Didier rayul this
very famous ibex is disease doctor MD
ph.d out of France and he's been
studying this for the last few weeks as
a treatment for patients with corner
virus and he had very positive results
as a very it was a small study just
about 36 people that stayed enrolled
till the end but it shoulder the
combination of hydroxychloroquine plus
azithromycin
so again hydroxy korkman is like cork
when it just actually has a safer side
effect profile so it's kind of used more
often than chloroquine but showed a very
small sample size still but showed a
hundred percent decrease in viral load
in in the hundred percent of the
patients receive both hydroxychloroquine
and as a therm Ison and so this is a
small kind of small sample size but very
positive results regarding this
treatment method and this was announced
by my co-author on tucker carlson last
night and it seems like Donald Trump
reacted to that as he in his press
conference today talked about it we
talked about anti-malarial medications
hydroxychloroquine how this needs to be
expedited and cut through the red tape
if possible to allow physicians to make
physicians feel comfortable in using
this drug to treat Koba 19 positive
patients it's pretty crazy that it seems
like many of these people are getting
their news from television or from
Twitter but it's human nature at this
point right a lot of this content that
gets shared around that's where people
are learning from walk us through what
is the difference between the
hydroxychloroquine I think it's how you
say it
and there's it throw Meissen what are
those two things kind of at the core
right and understanding that most of the
audience isn't going to be highly
scientific but just how would you just
share out those so hydroxychloroquine is
really used mainly as an
immunosuppressant so it's actually uses
for treatment in patients with
rheumatoid arthritis or
Lubas kind of suppresses the immune
system in a way to keep the body from
attacking itself it also again has
antiviral properties and anti-parasitic
properties so it's used as a
prophylactic or treatment for malaria
it's very popular in in Africa the therm
Ison is typically known as being an
antibiotic usually prescribed for
bacterial infections but studies have
shown that has antiviral properties so
corner virus is a virus it's not a
bacteria so that's a very important
difference that's why they can't give
you antibiotics for just a seasonal cold
I mean you could ask them people often
ask for them but it really isn't gonna
actually help because it's a totally
different type species but as a
thermite's it actually has antiviral
properties in bronchial epithelial cells
and this is where corona virus will
attach and in fact is a lot of the
respiratory tract and so as they throw
Meissen it makes sense why it could help
treat or be preventative treated for
your printer for corona virus got it and
then when you talk about those being
used in unison is this actually like a
scientific mixture right meaning that
you're creating one single solution by
combining these two or is this two
separate either shots or however they're
actually administered they're kept
separate but you basically take them at
the same time correct so in the French
study which is really the most data we
have at this time on this combination
therapy it's two separate pills so you
take your hydroxychloroquine and then
you take is at their Meissen and so what
he did for the hydroxy cork when it was
a 10-day treatment of it as 600
milligrams a day and then as a therm
Ison with a 500 milligram loading dose
the first day and then 250 milligrams
for I believe the next four days so oral
form separate pills but used in tandem
combination got it and so where do we go
from here right we've identified these
two drugs that we think have the
potential to be effective in treating
this we've got what I'll call kind of an
initial early study that shows some
encouraging results we obviously don't
have time to go through kind of
traditional process but as you mentioned
earlier we want to make sure people are
safe and actually can validate the
efficacy of this so like what does that
process look like or where do we go from
here
so I think one of the what I kind of
alluded to earlier one of the
interesting things about
hydroxychloroquine is so many people are
already on it so you already have a
million or so people so if there is a
way to analyze that data that already
exists and see if any of those people
are getting infected with coronavirus
and as the incidence or prevalence of
coronavirus goes up you should start to
see overlap you should start to see
lupus patients or rheumatoid arthritis
patients who are on hydroxy Bookman as
becoming infected and so if you were
able to create a study that could
analyze that group of people and maybe
it's two self-reported or some other
means then I mean I think a safe way to
evaluate the efficacy of this drug very
quickly as opposed to doing a controlled
trial where you're a placebo and all
that got it and so once we get past kind
of those studies so I think of studies
maybe correctly or incorrectly as the
way to gather data
we're like what are the milestones or
kind of the stamps of approval like what
does that look like is that the people
who run the study saying hey stamp of
approval this works is there some kind
of overarching like governing body or
government organization what is that
kind of approval process look like
before it can actually start being given
to patients kind of on the ground yeah
you so there's basically two different
ways so you either have to come to the
FDA with sufficient evidence to show
that this medication is safe and
beneficial in its treatment of a
specific disease that's the if you want
to call on label use so that's you know
what the prescription is designed for
it's a doctors also have the option
though to use medicines off-label which
means this is not the FDA approved
indication for it but doctors still have
the ability to prescribe medications
where they think appropriate are
necessary in patients that it's not the
the specific indication that the FDA
approves this is
things get interesting though because in
America's medicine is fairly litigious
so if you as a physician deviate from
that standard of care and then something
goes wrong even if that something went
wrong was a small percent and that could
happen to either you know as someone
with an fda-approved indication it still
makes you vulnerable to a lawsuit and
traditionally its academic physicians or
people or physicians are very
comfortable experimenting with new use
cases for these drugs and will see those
patients the problem we're seeing in a
pandemic is those physicians those
academic ones they kind of becoming
overwhelmed you have patients all over
so it's not just a very rare case of
something were you looking for a
position that will we'll treat this
thing with a softly off-label use you
have physicians everywhere that are kind
of stuck in this thing where do I use a
certain medication off-label for to
treat all these coronavirus patients
that are coming into my ward or do I
give them IV fluids and you know
hopefully get better and that's I think
the question that a lot of physicians in
the u.s. are dealing with right now and
so they're looking for some guidance
from the FDA essentially saying hey you
can use which that's what kind of what
Trump did a little bit today react T I
think back on that a little bit but he
essentially said look I'm approving
people for approving physicians to use
the this medication hydroxychloroquine
in coronavirus patients I don't know if
it's really that hard of a that that
really pass through it I think there's
still some red tape that maybe needs to
go through but that's essentially I
think what he's aiming it yeah it's
really interesting to see a lot of kind
of bureaucracies and red tape in the
healthcare system being almost broken
down in this crisis right so everything
from what you're talking about kind of
the acceleration or approval process to
you know the ability for a doctor to
actually administer healthcare services
to a patient in a different state right
a lot of telemedicine stuff etc for
those that aren't aware of how
bureaucratic healthcare is there's a lot
of rules that I think you kind of
mentioned earlier make sense sometimes
other times they seem really stupid
right and so it takes a crisis like this
to kind
break some of those down and then maybe
some of them get reinstated later or
maybe they don't but but it's just been
fascinating to me to kind of watch this
almost tennis match between here's the
rules today well should we keep them or
is this kind of an emergency situation
let's get rid of them yeah exactly you
kind of take a hard look and say wait
which of these rules are actually
high-yield and which ones are just you
know vestiges of old bureaucracy of it
is maybe due to obvious sir who knows
for sure and sort of finish up here
obviously you've got kind of two parts
of your brain right now I must think of
right you've got the the medical side
and the training that you've done there
and obviously the hours and hours that
you spent kind of looking at this I'm
starting to identify some of the
potential solutions but then you also
are an investor in your managing capital
and things like that where's the
crossover in terms of how do you see
coronavirus and the economic impact kind
of continuing over across different
markets in the coming weeks and months
yeah so it's constantly changing I think
you have to kind of look out for three
different potential paths coming up over
the next few months or years so there's
the first path where we do find a
medication a treatment or a prophylactic
they can flatten the curve reduce the
symptoms reduce the fatality rate or
reduce them where people that get
infected and that could bias time until
maybe a vaccines developed or even until
we have herd immunity and this thing in
front of our eyes just becomes almost
like the floor of a seasonal flu and not
really a big deal the second path is the
virus mutates a little bit so almost
like h1n1 where it was kind of thought
of as a big deal higher fertility rate
and then it kind of mutated in a way
where a lot of people got it so in fact
a lot of people but the mortality was
actually quite low so that's why I
didn't even hit the radar all that much
and most really know how many people are
actually affected by it and then the
third path would be that the virus does
not mutate it it we do not have a
medication your vaccine work then that's
scarier obviously and what I think you
could be looking at is maybe and this is
based off
in South Korea how the cases have
stabilized in a number of new cases is
dramatically dropping that is this have
to do with the warmer weather coming in
and are we gonna see a second wave
become the fall and that's what a lot of
people compare this to the Spanish flu
of 1918 where it had its first wave that
kind of ended around June July and it
wasn't until about October November the
second wave came in and that's the one
that really wiped out a lot of people
and so that's something is you're gonna
be looking out for is if this does
settle down that's great that's
fantastic but keeping a close eye for
infections in areas come the fall on a
short-term basis for Americans look at
Italy we're running about ten days
behind Italy so what Italy is going
through now will be America most likely
in ten days and this just seems so
obvious to me over the past couple weeks
and so that's what it is interested a
couple weeks ago almost no one was
really talking whereas almost like a
joke and you awkward if you weren't
shake someone's hand or something now
it's not if you actually just look at
those stories coming out of Italy about
the people living there what that life
is like prepare for that because that
could easily be America in ten days and
I think it's already getting very close
to that and so looking for stabilization
of crores again look at Italy when those
cases stopped going up and stabilized I
think that's good news and I think that
there's hope for this stabilizing at
least over the summer and then what to
revisit it in the fall
and then I think the market so Bitcoin
and Bitcoin cryptocurrency I think it
all kind of goes that way in something
this massive it seems like it kind of is
trading along with it when the economy
is going down it's it's risk on asset
and it goes down as well yeah one of the
things that I've heard and I don't know
if it's true or not is that once you get
coronavirus you basically can't get
reinfected right so the population
itself some portion could get infected
it goes away and comes back and could
reinfect other people but is it true
that the individual itself
once you have it you can't get it again
or is it just too early to know whether
that's accurate or not so that's
typically how viruses work once you get
a viral infection you can't get that
really exact same viral infection there
can be different strains of it though
that's why you can get the flu multiple
years it's not like you get the flu once
and you're no you never get the flu
again another strain think about the
next year or you might get fected with a
different strain even that year they are
finding though that they are patients
that test negative after they've been
treated later than test positive again
for the virus and so that's concerning
in some ways than the thought that are
they not treating patients long enough
is this some type of reinfection and so
that is that data's being studied now
but I'm inclined to think that's how you
get here in a herd immunity is
potentially as you if you get infected
you won't get it again so that's kind of
a hope but it's not definitive at this
point got it and those different strains
I think the other thing I've heard is
basically when the warm weather comes it
may kind of migrate south to South
America Latin America etc but there
could be mutations and then when the
cold weather returns later this year
North America for example that's where
really there could be some problems
because now you're not just talking
about the corona virus but there could
be multiple strains of this or kind of
mutations that even if you already had
it you're still susceptible to the new
stuff yeah exactly I think that one
thing that people argue that for going
away during the summer is increased
temperature will dry out the the virus
in some ways and then also the increased
humidity so it's gonna give this heat
tennis Sun drying up like then you also
have a humidity in the air which will
stop the spread of the virus because if
there's enough air water particles in
the aerial stop the the viral particles
from kind of you know projecting when
you talk or sneeze your call got it
that's super interesting okay and then
what do you think is kind of the if you
had a guess right now what does this
look like
over the next kind of six to eight weeks
do we flatten a curve you know two weeks
from now and and kind of start moving
back towards you know everyday life do
we stay in kind of this self quarantined
you know even sometimes a shelter in
place for for weeks months like how do
you think this plays out given the
information you have today you're gonna
be pointing for at least weeks I would
say at least a month it could be couple
months three months it kind of depends
on this thesis on this thing slowing
down for the summer
but I think we're in for a rocky few
weeks coming up and it looked like Italy
was stabilized a little bit but then
they recorded a record number of new
cases yesterday and another record
number it looks like today so it's we
haven't had any yeah there's been no
evidence this is slowing down really for
Italy or Europe and so that that's not
good news for us right now either got it
and then what do you take in terms of
China I think today we're recording on a
on Thursday March 19th
it was either yesterday or today they
reported no new cases so you know
quote-unquote zero new cases can we
trust the data you know how do you kind
of fit that data point into this whole
thing so I'm an in contact with people
that have come back in China and they
feel convinced that China has it under
control and that that data is real
that's always been the question that was
from the very beginning you know China
didn't really want to announce that this
was the virus you had the whistleblowers
they're originally persecuted and now
praised and so there is this always this
distrust of the information from China
but South Korea has kind of very
positive results I think Singapore has
been doing a good job controlling this
and so it's possible it's also possible
in the kind of social infrastructure
side of things I think in China and in
South Korea you know the social
distancing is maybe a lot easier or if
the government recommends it or imposes
it it's done much more effectively
whereas in Italy in the u.s. you know
like well screw that I I know I'm gonna
go kiss whoever's cheek I want I'm gonna
go to the bars and so I think that it
really takes a little bit more to scare
people and now people I started to get
scared where maybe there
scaling back on that a little bit but if
you read a lot of the Italians what
they're telling Americans right now is
do that now
don't don't wait until it gets so bad
that you you know there's a curfew you
can get if you're outside I can check
and Italy right now if you go outside
you have to essentially have a pass or a
very good evidence of a reason for being
out otherwise you get fined and the only
reason you really ought to go out is to
go pick up medication or to go to
grocery stores yeah I the other thing I
just saw literally right before we
started recording and again so I came
out with I haven't had the time to look
at the accuracy of it is Israel is
actually implementing martial law so
like the actual true martial law where
the government or the military is going
to enforce people staying inside curfews
you know all of this kind of
non-essential traffic etc and so I think
that we're probably far away away from
that you know in the US for example or
other places but you know depending on
people's reactions I think that yeah
there is this overarching feeling of
like we've got to flatten that curve and
kind of fight back against us I would
say there's a nonzero chance some
version of martial law comes to the US
as well in the next 2-3 weeks I mean if
if this thing continues a spread and
people aren't voluntarily isolating
themselves then it's definitely possible
I would it wouldn't surprise me the next
two or three weeks which sounds crazy
huh
for American it's especially cuz a lot
of Americans have guns once a little bit
of a different well III was explaining
some of the other day if you would have
said four or five weeks ago you know hey
the stock marks then go down 30% there's
the possibility of martial law you know
all these different things people look
at you like you're nuts and in a very
short period of time you know here we
are yeah exactly and I think that people
could be in for a bit more surprises in
the next couple weeks yeah well let's
let's all hope not and hopefully we go
to the master over there but they're
going to get back to normal life
absolutely yep James listen I really
appreciate you coming on on such short
notice and
helping us understand this where can
people find you online and kind of find
more about what what you're tracking I'm
in paying attention to James sodaro MD
is my Twitter account looks like Joe
just put it on the screen there that's
the best way to polish it
I know it's quick that's where I talk
about corner - updates a lot of times
its effect and the Bitcoin
cryptocurrency markets and that's what I
talked about on my crypto insights as
well
awesome before I let you go I got two
questions that you get asked me one a
favorite book or most important book
you've ever read was a book every read
gosh I guess Treasure Island for no real
reason except there was a book that is
by the first very sophisticated book
that my dad read to me he read it to me
when I was very very young and is
actually funny cuz he I felt like he was
too slow so after he read the first
maybe few chapters of it actually just
picked up and read the rest of the book
of my own and so that only stands out in
my mind I love that it's it's one of
those things where it's not only the
book but the time of your life when you
read it that doesn't make something a
big that's pretty cool exactly
aliens livre or non-believer I think
there is life somewhere out there in
another universe in some way it isn't
that I think that's definitely possible
just because the world so you know kind
of the galaxy so big or some other
reason
I mean infinite with infinity of an
infinite number of possibilities right
so you can have an infinite combinations
of matter that can form humans or people
or animals or life it's a fair way to
view the world one question you have for
me to finish up jeez does anyone ever
call you Anthony or is it always pump so
my mother still calls me Anthony my
family they actually all call me AJ my
Anthony John
my name so they called me initials for
first middle name but pretty much today
sorry calls me Anthony it's usually
followed up with by the way can I call
you pop or is that are we not like close
enough yet and I tell people that you
can call me whatever you want just don't
call me an [ __ ] and we'll be good
antthony pop whatever it offers for me
alright man
well it's great talking to you thanks
for having me on the show yeah thanks so
much James appreciate it
I have a good one